[Musique]
après deux semaines de négociations
tendues et les seuils de sang et des la
coop 26 accouche enfin d'un accord ouais
d'accord a minima qui n'assure pas de
contenir le réchauffement climatique et
5 degrés d'ici la fin du siècle un
accord qui ne répond pas non plus aux
demandes dette des pays pauvres je suis
profondément désolé je comprends aussi
la profonde déception de certains mais
je pense qu'il est vital devant être que
nous protégions cet accord ne vais pas
vous donner un scoop là dessus on ne
pourra le faire que si tous les
engagements qui sont pris par les pays
il y a des engagements qui ont été pris
notamment grâce à cette coque soit
appliquée s'ils ne sont pas appliqués
s'ils ne sont pas mis en oeuvre oui je
vous confirme qu'on ne sera pas dans les
1,5 degré et ce sera très grave on
aurait voulu effectivement que la chine
et l'inde soit plus engagé socialement
et sur le long terme bien sûr puisque
comme une résonance cette image
alarmante en inde où la population
baigne depuis plusieurs jours dans un
épais brouillard pollution atmosphérique
qui étaient à des niveaux
catastrophiques à tel point que new
delhi a ordonné la fermeture des écoles
prône ce mail et fonctionnaires doivent
télétravail et les entreprises privées
sont invitées à le faire aussi parmi les
avancées une quarantaine de pays
s'engagent à sortir du charbon entre
2030 et 2040 et 107 autres veulent
réduire leurs émissions de méthane de
30% en dix la prochaine conférence sur
le climat se déroulera en egypte en 2022
mais avant cela chaque pays signataire
doit soumettre aux nations unies sa
stratégie de réduction de carbone
engagements chiffrés à l'appui personne
ni gentil là dedans ni la pologne et la
biélorussie ni la lituanie ni les russes
personnes n'existent pas les gentils en
politique internationale donc il s'agit
traiter une crise notre intérêt que la
pression redescende est ce que les
russes ont dernière cette manoeuvre à
mon avis mais ce n'est que mon avis
certainement pas tellement elle est
grossière et tellement elle est
maladroite dès son arrivée la venue
d'eric zemmour suscite la colère et
l'indignation
/
sera menée avec les caméras et cetera
devant le bataclan ccc c'est vraiment
une attitude de vautours de charognards
président de la république ce n'est pas
seulement organiser des marches blanches
ce n'est pas seulement mais allumé des
bougies et monter des grandes
manifestations avec tous les chefs
d'état du monde c'est défendre les
français contre la guerre qui nous est
menée et comme dans toute crise vous
avez des tristes sires vous avez des
profiteurs de guerre vous avez des
prophètes de malheur qui se servent des
crises pour essayer de capitaliser
politiquement sur les angoisses des
français sur les colères des français ça
veut dire que la campagne présidentielle
va être un peu nauséabond
la précampagne et de toute façon d'une
grande violence en france heureusement
lui même admet à l'occasion du procès
que précisément ils savaient ils avaient
des informations certaines comme quoi
les renseignements lui avait indiqué
qu'il y aurait parmi le flot de réfugiés
de potentiels terroristes envoyé par
dave les déclarations de eric zemmour
sont à la fois un fonds d indécentes et
à digne s'est même entendu à l'époque
avec angela merkel pour organiser
l'arrivée de ces migrants de manière là
de manière durable d'après
d'intervention à l'intention encore une
ombre parce que terre mais parce que je
pense que l'intention de françois
hollande c'était une intention naïvement
humaniste c'est le françois hollande lui
même qu'il le reconnaît et vous n'avez
qu'à reprendre l'article du monde le
monde de 2016 qui explique exactement ce
qui s'est passé qui est conforme à tout
ce que j'ai dit c'est de la surenchère
c'est de la polémique et c'est même de
l'outrance et c'est même de la jure par
rapport à ce qui s'est produit cette
nuit là stéphane bern explique pourquoi
il quitte paris je n'en peux plus la
saleté les trous dans la chaussée les
chantiers permanents le bruit et surtout
surtout la violence monsieur patrimoine
n'y va pas de main morte